hey everybody I'm Alex and this here is
Ed and we were with gamespot like III
2015 day 3 and a 3 we just saw destiny
the taken King story mode for the press
we played through the very first story
mission of destiny taking king so we've
already talked about pvp stuff so we
probably won't go into the classes so
much but we want to go through what
happened in this story mission because
it's a little bit different to what yeah
we've seen so far in destiny right so
the basically the setup of the of the
taking king's story is that you end up
encountering crotas father Oryx and
aurochs is coming after you for revenge
for killing Croatoan the last expansion
and so really what the story mode is is
your first like the one that we played
is your first encounter with this like
giant godlike figure yeah so it's the
setup is like you fly down the planet
right and what's the guy's name
commander zavala yeah he's like oh
something's going on in this cabal
planet and its really what setup is so
strange it's like a horror write a
horror scene could you fly down in the
first enemy you see is a cabal reasoner
the late little internet and he's as
soon as I so much wanted to shoot him
right but he was just a set-piece it was
like going on the ground you know like
oh like kind of stuff and very
atmospheric yeah it actually it was like
two or three minutes before you could
actually shoot anything there you know
the Cabal all over the place but they're
all like dying they're all crawling and
there's when you look out into the sky
box there you know ships coming in
there's just all sorts of things just
you know poppin off explosions happening
is it to me it felt a lot like some of
those setups of the missions of you know
old bungee games like Halo games yeah
absolutely and then you eventually get
to a room and they're like these we'd
void things yeah well yes so black and
white static right so like the new enemy
type and the taken king is called the
taken yeah and they're these yeah you
know an apt name and they're these
enemies are cabal they're like following
and stuff that have been taken by Oryx
and turn into these like weird black and
white interdimensional monsters
basically evil version yeah they're
already evil sales yeah and their
behaviors like way different as well
they they have different weapons they
move differently it's super strange to
you know see ya like Eric T our destiny
fiend gains but was saying it was very
similar to what they didn't Wow we're
like some some big enemy would be like
I'm taking all taken over all you other
guys as well so then you get the enemy
variety so we were fighting like hive
enemies and Cabala nice is that right
yeah and I think there might have been a
fallen or to throw little too yeah and
they were just like fighting amongst
themselves fighting with us that kind of
stuff so it was a short mission there
was only one dachshund a darkness zone
and yeah it was pretty damn cool yeah I
really liked the enemy animations
actually they this this is in the
trailer but we got to see it firsthand
they have this weird shaky like judder
yeah because they're kind of
interdimensional so they really are
caught between two worlds I think that's
really where the story is going and so
when you're fighting these taken it's
kind of like you're fighting these these
creatures who aren't really there but
also you know behave weight differently
than you expect them to absolutely and
the the final shot of the mission once
them once Oryx came out and like this
gigantic Oryx head is like you killed my
son and I'm gonna get you it's you know
there's Bella dramatic he's a one of
these these sword bearers comes down and
then you find him you kill him and then
you rush out out of the the base cuz
might as well is like get the hell out
of there this missions cancelled and you
just see a massive planets cape of like
like this wall going on right I'm just
like ships coming down crashing it's
epic as hell is the most epic destiny
level I've seen like it really channels
the old epicness of Halo games and this
really like I was really surprised at
how much they're going for this giant
you know epic feel of war but they have
not lost the sense of humor there was a
great line in that demo where eris morn
is who is the the quest giver in the dot
below comes on to the columns to give
advice and she says something like this
is during the horror section and she
said something like I can feel the
fingernails on my brain yeah and that is
a Muslim thanks for your input
yeah so yeah you know the the dialogue
is still it's pretty funny but you know
the epicness is there and it made me
really excited to see what's what's in
store for the yep and the taken King
yeah I am really looking forward to
taking King off to seeing and playing
all the stuff that's been here at e3
yeah so that's our hands-on impressions
of the story mode in the taken King for
all things the new Justin expansion key
to lock key to gamespot com